please buy me that pink food I would
like that pink food please put it in my
mouth thank you it's so exciting we are
trying limited edition peeps Oreo
cookies let me do the dish
I guess I'm surprised that there's no
Oreo based religion because Oreos are so
freakin good that they make me believe
in something I'm big on color that's the
thing that peeps do have to offer I like
peace more than Oreos the sugar-coated
crust it's the best an Oreo dunked in
milk is one of the finest pleasures
honor peeps Oreos two things I would
never have thought to combine but you
know maybe it's a match made in heaven
I think I'm ready to peep those cookies
oh it smells like happiness was like
play-doh us also smells like Halloween
it smells like cake frosting if my life
just smell like this everyday it would
be a good life there's no sugary crust
here we go
Wow no I'm into it the texture is a
little like pop rocky sugar in there
that's like a whole party just tastes
like cake frosting I feel like my
dentist is somewhere right now very
upset I do like the cookie the cookie is
classic cookie tastes like a trap oil
what a trap oil it's a Girl Scout cookie
and that's what this tastes like and I'm
kind of into that I do appreciate the
texture I mean I love this I would rank
it above a piece and below a normal Oreo
but really a class I probably eat them
again here's the thing or you you don't
need to better yourself you're just
perfect the way you are
I admire the collaboration good good
partnership actually what happen
otherone
I want to see a Doritos flavor Cool
Ranch Oreos what's disgusting Wow